[Applause]
you know as promised I you know I think
a lot of youngsters they you know they
Revere you so they they'd up to the
other thing you inspire is impressions
people doing impressions now when people
do impressions of you is it like sort of
nails on a chalkboard or do you kind of
enjoy it no I I kind of enjoy it
especially if they do it well so no I
it's great I love it I only ask no
because because any Hiddleston who's
watching will know and Tom Hiddleston
does impression you do what there's a
lot of people who is in your Canon it's
a it's a expression of admiration just
to be clear so I do I do her impressions
of people that I admire and I sort of
listen to them I get the first time I
did an impression a burn and anyone was
aware of I was just telling a story
about Midnight in Paris the Woody Allen
film I was in and how I never had the
whole script tonight and I thought it
was set in the 20s and I turned up and I
bonded own Wilson who didn't look like
he was in the 20s at all and and I said
to him I said so wait hang on who are
you playing cuz I'm playing f scott
Fitzgerald and I know Corey stars
playing Ernest Hemingway and we're all
playing figures of history anew and
there's a time machine it's kind of cool
and it's kind of wooden you just Connor
is kind of Awesome
[Applause]
I've been made to do impressions of my
fellow Avengers I think everyone does an
impression of Christopher Walken because
he's such an easy kind of you know I
feel like what this show needs is more
cowbell depends on what you like me to
say basically there's no punctuation
anything that comes out of my mouth
I know whole pages of heat you surprised
me
so I there's this there's a scene in the
middle of the film which you'll be
familiar with you
[Laughter]
in the middle of the film which is
because because Al Pacino Robert DeNiro
[Laughter]
separated like a great thriller they're
separated from for the entire film and
they meet twice once at the end or once
in the middle and it takes place at a
restaurant la it's a great scene it's
one of the great pieces of screen acting
you can hope to watch there it is it
says the picture it's like it's a mutual
recognition of each other anyway so
there's a bit where they have like this
sit and have coffee and had tea and talk
about stuff I'm going on I apologize to
you know at one point
Albertina says this he goes so we're
sitting here like a couple of regular
fellows I mean you do what you do I do
what I gotta do if I'm there and I gotta
put you away I won't like it but if it's
between you and some poor bastard whose
wife you're gonna turn into a widow
brother you are going down Michael man
cuts back to the esteemed gentleman at
the end of the sofa what if you do got
me boxed in I'm not gonna put you down
I'm even face to face yeah but I will
not hesitate not for a second
that's my
[Applause]
gone into a parallel universe where I
can browse my favorite team there was he
kept everything yeah it still yeah that
was written before not because of our
doing it but I just my favorite scene
written in the yeah you know that it's a
great piece right yeah it feels like it
plays into into singles in a way like
yeah yeah yeah and it's it's like it the
most beautiful game of tennis did you do
lots of takes what did you do lots of
times okay how many takes we do I don't
think we did more than five to eight or
nine that may be a nebula so you talk
about your dreams and you talk about
your life not a bit where you go he says
Pacino says so you never wanted a
regular type life and Bob may I call you
Bob yeah Bob says what's that barbecues
and ballgames yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that's something I'm not even put up and
put that out into
[Laughter]